اذا قلنا انه ساحر العظام فذلك لانه يحقق
انجازات طبيه من التصوير الى التاهيل
ومرضى الامريكيون باتوا حديثا مواقع
التواصل الطبيب السعودي دكتور عاصم مخدوم
يمارس هذا السحر الطبي بين السعوديه
وامريكا وكندا قدم محاضرات عن جراحات
وعمليات تبديل مفصل الركبه اما اكثر من
3000 جراح مفاصل من مختلف دول العالم
يشاركه عبر مقاطع التواصل الاجتماعي نصائح
طبيه تتعلق بالحفاظ على صحه العظام
والركبات وينشر مقاطع قبل وبعد لمرضى
تعافى تماما وفورا بعد عمليات اليوم
الواحد لتغيير المفاصل واصبح يمارسون
حياتهم بشكل طبيعي بعد 12 عاما قضاها في
امريكا وكندا يدرس ويجري ابحاثه عملياته
عاده دكتور عاصم الى الوطن يخدم الان في
احد المستشفيات مدينه جده
يوم واحد لتبديل مفصل الركبه حدثنا اكثر
طيب اول شيء خشونه الركبه اتكلم عنها
خشونه الركبه هو للاسف الشديد مرض شائع
همم موجود بشكل كبير في طبعا له اسباب
وراثيه في اسباب تتعلق بزياده الوزن
عصابات قديمه في الركبه العلاج ما هو
دائما يكون بتبديل نفس الرقم هذا العلاج
النهائي اذا كانت الخشونه جدا جدا شديده
نقطه التبديل هنا الان همم تقليديه ان
الناس طبعا او شائع انه هذه عمليه خطيره
وصعبه ونسبه نجاحها ما هي عاليه همم طبعا
مع التقنيات الحديثه في خلال اخر خمسه او
عشره سنوات صرنا نسميها عمليات اليوم
الواحد وهمم والتاهيل السريع بمعنى ان
المريض همم يدخل يسوي العمليه ممكن يخرج
في نفس اليوم ويجلس 24 ساعه همم في
المستشفى
المريض يمشي بعد العمليه مباشره بعد ساعات
جلوسه في المستشفى يكون 24 ساعه طبعا في
مرضى يكون عندهم مشاكل صحيه همم اخرى غير
الركبه مثلا مشاكل في القلب وغيرها هيحتاج
همم انه يجلس اكثر من 24 ساعه
45 دقيقه
45 دقيقه تقريبا همم همم ليش هذا الشيء
صار انه الحمد لله تطورت الجراحه بشكل مره
كبير
وانواع المفاصل المستخدمه تطورت بشكل كبير
فخطوات العمليه صارت اقل طيب دكتور الا
اما هذه العمليه ترتبط بالبنيه الجسديه
للمريض وقوهته
مهم لانه في بعض المرضى بسبب الخوف من
العمليه
يقوم بتاجيل العمليه سنين وسنين مشكله
تاجيل العمليه اذا كانت الخشونه شديده
يصير عندك العضلات فيها الضمور فانا
احيانا يقول لي متضايع في العياده طيب
يعني احنا ممكن نسوي تبديل بس اذا لم يوجد
عضلات بسبب ضمورها بالتالي يكون التاهيل
جدا صعب ولذلك
الان نصيحه للمرضى انه اذا كانت الخشونه
عندك شديده ووجدت الاستشاري المختص ونصحك
بالعمليه
فلابد انك تختار الوقت المناسب اللي هو
تكون الصحه ما زال جيده العضلات مازال
جيده والطبيب طبعا الماهر
[موسيقى]